alors ce soir je veux le redire avec
beaucoup de force et beaucoup de
conviction la vaccination est notre plus
sûrs atouts elle réduit fortement la
transmission elle divise par dix le
nombre des formes graves c'est pour cela
qu'une nouvelle fois j'en appelle aux 5
millions de non vaccinés fait ce geste
simple pour vous pour vos compatriotes
pour notre pays toute la france compte
sur vous
la vaccination est elle seule suffisante
non c'est pour cela que le respect des
gestes barrières contre le virus demeure
essentiel en particulier le port du
masque tous ensemble nous allons donc
traverser cette nouvelle épreuve en
suivant les mêmes principes que depuis
le premier jour d'abord nous protéger
protéger les plus vulnérables protéger
nos hôpitaux et nos soignants qui sont
sous forte pression alors même qu'il
faut soigner les autres maladies
protéger aussi notre économie et nos
emplois comme nous l'avons fait avec le
quoi qu'il en coûte ensuite nous
attacher sur la base des faits de la
science à prendre des mesures
proportionnées
c'est exactement ce que le premier
ministre et les ministres ont fait ces
derniers jours tout faire pour éviter de
prendre des restrictions qui pèsent sur
nos libertés et veiller à respecter tous
nos principes démocratiques
enfin nous appuyer sur la responsabilité
de chacun
principalement se faisant vacciner pour
soi et pour les autres être un citoyen
libre et toujours être un citoyen
responsable pour soi et pour autrui les
devoirs valcke avant les droits